at warwick university a protest calling
for greater protection for female
students
most here have a story of abuse
first-year ade musa
says a fellow student came to her room
uninvited
he said are you okay with this and i
said i don't want to do anything at all
he took off his trousers and he said
that all i had to do was kiss it and
then he would go
essentially he ended up making me a
for all like sexual activities on him
i didn't really leave my house for
months after that because
i was so scared of seeing him in on
campus or anything
have you reported him the thing is it's
my word against his
there's not really much the university
would be able to do warwick was hit by
scandal in 2018 when a group of male
students shared
sexually violent messages with each
other online
concerns about misogyny and abuse in
higher education
mira what's recently emerged from
testimonies about independent schools
and young women say the two things are
connected
they have almost this ego problem
and this lack of respect towards women
which leads them to
carrying on coercing people or in some
cases even forcing people into these
situations because
they're so used to getting everything
that they want warwick university told
us sexual misconduct will not be
tolerated and more can be done to tackle
it
but incidents of sexual abuse in english
and welsh universities were found to be
in the tens of thousands
when research was published last
november the scale of the problem is
much bigger than
we had anticipated it is at least 50 000
from the research that we've done
um and it is distressing and that's
every year
now that that those sexual assaults go
from being groped
to actually being raped so they would
use the spreadsheet to
to write down which girls were the
easiest target to have sex with
zan moon sent pages of written
testimonies by young women
to top private schools about the
behaviour of their male
pupils these young boys aren't being
taught
the right lessons in life about consent
women's rights feminism from a young age
and they're forming beliefs around
misogynistic culture that they've been
brought up in in those schools and then
taking that forth into universities
it would be really helpful to reform sex
education completely
provide rehabilitation programs within
schools for perpetrators
and in perhaps pe
we could provide self-defense lessons
for women
a former male student from one of the
schools tunbridge agrees with what's
being said
it starts in like year 9 year 10 with
you know people making like
like stupid sexist jokes or whatever and
like misogyny strokes and those
do then go unchecked by your peers
clearly as the testimonies show they're
translating real
actions of harassing and assaulting
women
the schools cited in zanz dossier
including tunbridge
say they take these matters seriously
and are reviewing
their procedures jason farrell sky news